und jetzt das heute journal
mit sky soll richter und marietta slomka
guten abend den besuch bei der queen hat
boris johnson bereits absolviert nun
dürfte es schlag auf schlag gehen
der wahlsieg der tories ist so deutlich
ausgefallen dass johnson seinen rexit
kurs durchziehen kann ohne noch auf
irgendwelche parteiinternen kritiker
rücksicht nehmen zu müssen
auf die opposition eh nicht schwierig
wird es erst wieder wenn er auf die
europäer trifft denn ausgehandelt für
die zeit nach dem break cit ist ja noch
nichts
schwierig wird es auch mit den schotten
werden bei denen es ebenfalls einen
klaren wahlsieger gibt die
proeuropäische nationalpartei und
schwierig wird es auch in nordirland
great britain stehen dann noch bewegte
zeiten bevor
doch heute durfte johnson erst mal
seinen triumph genießen
seine strategie ist voll aufgegangen
während die nieder der niederlage von
labour historische ausmaße hat
andreas stamm berichtet ein tag der
viele verlierer kennt geschockte
gesichter labour anhänger praxis gegner
die gehofft hatten auf eine überraschung
die ausblieb und ein tag der einen
großen sieger sieht boris johnson seine
konservativen im freudentaumel
wir werden endlich den brekzie
durchziehen ihr habt gut aufgepasst
nach fünf wochen wahlkampf und
schlafmangel kennt boris johnson story
an diesem tag wenig grenzen
wir stellen eine volksregierung wir
haben wahlkreise geholt die die
konservativen 100 jahre nicht gewonnen
haben durch ein klares versprechen dass
wir beherzigen werden bis zum 31 januar
den eu austritt erledigen volksregierung
der enorme zuwachs auf 365 sitze im
parlament eine absolute mehrheit
auch eine folge des mehrheitswahlrechts
denn die konservativen bleiben deutlich
unter 50 prozent der wählerstimmen legen
nur leicht zu doch dieser tag zeigt auch
was unverändert geblieben ist die
spaltung des landes in brax it gegner
und befürworter
die austritts gegner müssen nun aber
akzeptieren es wird kein zweites
referendum geben
der zug ist abgefahren diese hälfte
sollte nun auf einen weichen dragset
hinarbeiten der eine enge
wirtschaftliche bindung an die eu bringt
ein wenig trost für den verlierer des
tages jeremy corbijn es war eine praxis
wahl der oppositionsführer wollte nach
langem hin und her ein zweites
referendum das lehnte ein großer teil
traditioneller labour wähler ab von
denen noch mehr ihn nicht als premier
wollte ich werde die partei führen bis
ein neuer vorsitzender gewählt ist dann
zurücktreten
davon ist sie weit entfernt nicolas
turgeon chefin der schottischen
nationalisten fast alle wahlkreise in
schottland gewonnen aus ihrer sicht ein
tag an der der landesteil einen großen
schritt richtung unabhängigkeit macht ob
dir unabhängig werden wollen oder nicht
sollte nun allein in unseren händen
liegen für johnson alles weit weg am tag
an dem nicht nur intern downing street
glückwünsche auf ihn einprasseln glück
dass er brauchen wird im kampf um die
einheit des königreichs für die zeit
nach dem offiziellen eu austritt wenn
die verhandlungen über die künftigen
beziehungen erst richtig los ging das
die tories mit boris johnson eine
mehrheit erringen würden entsprach den
prognosen die frage war nur wie groß sie
ausfallen würde
und das ließ sich wegen des britischen
wahlsystems gar nicht vorhersagen
denn gewählt wird ja nicht landesweit
sondern quasi in 650 einzel wahlen bei
denen pro wahlkreis immer nur der
relative gewinner ins parlament einzieht
selbst wenn der abstand nur wenige
stimmen beträgt
winner takes it all welche auswirkungen
das haben kann sieht man wenn man
landesweite stimmenanteile mit den
parlamentssitzen vergleicht im vergleich
zur letzten wahl haben die tories im
parlament stolze 47 sitze dazugewonnen
ein erdrutschsieg den stimmanteilen
haben sie landesweit aber nur um 1,2
prozentpunkte zugelegt labour wiederum
verlor 7 8 prozentpunkte
das ist viel
aber nicht so dramatisch wie ihr verlust
an parlamentssitzen
da haben sie 59 abgeordnete verloren und
darin liegt auch die ganze wucht der
katastrophe für labour die partei hat es
bei dieser schicksalswahl nicht
geschafft regierungskritiker hinter sich
zu vereinen
viele boris oder praxis gegner wählten
den liberalen oder die grünen obwohl sie
wussten dass deren kandidaten im
wahlkreis chancenlos sind
doch lieber eine verlorene stimme als
eine für labour labour hatte offenkundig
die falsche strategie und vor allem den
falschen partei dazu eine analyse von
diana zimmermann der labour vorsitzende
belagert von der presse die allgemeine
erwartung nach dem schlechtesten
ergebnis für seine partei seit 1935 ist
er muss zurücktreten
doch der mann zeichnet sich durch
bedächtigkeit aus ich werde die parteien
nicht in die nächsten wahlen führen ich
werde mit der partei diskutieren um
sicherzustellen dass wir nun in einem
prozess des nachdenkens eintreten
manchen in der partei ist das zu wenig
und zu spät margaret hodge etwa seit 25
jahren abgeordnete ärgerte sich im netz
corvin spricht von zeit zum nachdenken
ich habe nachgedacht du hast versagt
bitte tritt zurück
fast jeder vierte labour-abgeordnete hat
seinen sitz verloren schuld so die
analysen waren die schwammige brachse
position von labour das ambitioniert
linke wirtschaftsprogramm des vielen zu
schön um wahr zu sein ein klares
versagen die zahlreichen fälle von
antisemitismus in der partei in den
griff zu bekommen vor allem aber der
kandidat selbst
neben den brachialen boris johnson sagt
jeremy carr bin sehr harmlos aus ich mag
corbijn nicht ich vertraue ihm nicht
überhaupt nicht nur einer hat das zu
verantworten und das ist jeremy kurven
keiner mag
das ist nicht wahr unter den jungen
erfreut sich der alte herr großer
beliebtheit und der linke parteiflügel
der kolben an die macht gebracht hat
verehrt den 70-jährigen als retter des
sozialismus die rechte presse aber fand
in ihm eine hassfigur karikierte ihn als
kommunisten und sicherheitsrisiko vor
allem unter den arbeitern in der
arbeiterpartei machte er bald keinen
stich mehr für erste und größte fehler
der labour-partei war es kommen
überhaupt zum vorsitzenden zu machen
man kann nicht erwarten das vertrauen
der briten zu gewinnen wenn man da
jemanden hin setzt der nach ansicht der
breiten bevölkerung unpatriotisch
schwach und unentschieden ist und in
sachen kriminalität terrorismus und
sicherheit als inkompetent geld die zahl
der parteimitglieder hat sich unter
jeremy corbijn verdoppelt gemeinsam mit
den großen gewerkschaften werden diese
den oder die nächste vorsitzende
bestimmen labour steht ein machtkampf
zwischen fundis und realos ins haus kein
neues problem für die europäische linke
so großbritannien wollen ein kommentar
von chefredakteur des zdf peter frey der
exit dann das versprechen den praxis
endlich über die bühne zu bringen das
brachte boris johnson die absolute
mehrheit voraussetzung für seinen
triumph war dass jeremy corbin die
traditionsreiche labour partei ins linke
abseits geführt hat robin hat nicht
gegen gehalten keine klare position zum
praxisbezogen so hatte großbritannien
die wahl zwischen einem lauten clown und
einem skurrilen außenseiter in einer
phase extremer verwirrung haben sich die
wähler für den lauten entschieden der
auch vor lügen nicht zurückschreckte
endlich klarheit das dachten sie heute
auch in brüssel oder an den börsen
dabei ist das zweite votum der briten
gegen das projekt europa vor allem
traurig mit dem vereinigten königreich
verliert gerade deutschland einen zwar
oft störrischen für die balance der
gemeinschaft aber sehr wichtigen partner
das wahlergebnis bestätigt den riss
zwischen jungen und alten zwischen den
metropolen und den die
industrialisierten ländlichen räumen im
zeitalter der globalisierung erschien
die eu zu vielen briten als teil des
problems und nicht als bollwerk gegen
ungezügelte märkte offenbar werden
freihandel zollabbau freizügigkeit von
waren und arbeitnehmern in der eu nicht
überall als errungenschaft sondern als
bedrohung wahrgenommen
das britische wahlergebnis enthält eine
warnung wenn es brüssel nicht gelingt
neben dem motor der wirtschaft auch zum
schutzschild der schwachen zu werden
dann drohen noch weitere exits der neuen
nationalismus siegt im mutterland der
demokratie
das schwächt das projekt europa im kern
und nach dem wahlergebnis in schottland
droht dass großbritannien so wie wir es
kennen und lieben zu zerbrechen nach
johnsons durchmarsch ist der albtraum
noch lange nicht zu ende
peter frei kommentierte die anderen
europäer wollten den rexit nicht doch
wenigstens gibt es jetzt endlich eine
klare entscheidung nach mehr als drei
jahren hängepartie mit wechselnden
britischen regierungs personal das nur
eingeschränkt verhandlungsfähig war
nun kann man nach vorne schauen und
handelsabkommen aushandeln
darin hat die eu maschinerie einige
expertise oder krüger berichtet wie in
brüssel die nachrichten aus london
aufgenommen wurden und was der eu-gipfel
sonst noch an erkenntnissen brachte
es ist der erste gipfel ohne die briten
und doch geht letzten acht ein raunen
durch die presse war großes echo auf
johnsons riesig doch dazu später mehr
denn die tagesordnung dieses gipfels
zeigt es gibt für die eu wie der
wichtigeres als den dreck cit vor allem
ein klimaziel ursula von der leyen will
eine ausgeglichene co2 bilanz und das in
drei jahrzehnten dafür bekommt sie die
unterstützung aller staats und
regierungschefs jedenfalls beinahe ich
bin unter den gegebenen umständen
ehrlich gesagt recht zufrieden denn wenn
man mal ein jahr zurück denken da war
von klimaneutralität 2050 noch überhaupt
gar nicht die rede vom energiemix reden
stattdessen alle und erklären damit den
sonderbaren gipfel kompromiss alle sind
sich einig aber nicht alle machen mit
polen hängt zu 80 am klimaschädlichen
kohlestrom sein premier erhält deshalb
einen aufschub bis juni steht aber unter
beobachtung
infinera polen polen am ende nicht sagt
wie es zu dem ziel beitragen will dann
erhält es auch keine finanzielle hilfe
aus europa denn das ist die frage wer
bekommt von brüssel was für den
energieumbau was ist klimafreundlich
tschechien etwa will atomkraft als
saubere energiequelle einstufen für den
ausbau so verlangt es der premier solle
auch die eu seien alle nutzen das und
und alle hassen diese dieses wort und
ich habe das gestern durchgesetzt weil
das ist natürlich die einzige
möglichkeit für tschechien die
neutralität zu erreichen
er übertreibt denn kernkraft als
klimaretter steht so nicht im kompromiss
und doch von der leyen muss lernen
symbole gibt es umsonst klimarettung nur
gegen geld
die staats und regierungschefs sind
schon auf dem absprung als sie der black
cit doch noch einholt
das ist positiv die mehrheit für johnson
wir sind auf halben weg jetzt müssen wir
neue beziehungen verhandelt dafür geben
sie der neuen kommission ein neues
mandat die chefin geht und kommt zurück
rexit ist eben doch ein thema
die zeit ist extrem kurz deshalb setzen
wir auch sehr klare schwerpunkte auf die
themen
[Musik]
so verhandelt werden müssen dass wir am
ende des jahres nicht eine situation
wider einer eines hardware exit haben
wieder wird es dabei auf europas
einigkeit einkommen beim warten auf die
limousine leid der luxemburger klavier
bettelte kommissionschefin seinen schal
wie zum symbol europa steht in der kälte
aber doch wenigstens zusammen ums
deutsche waffenrecht ging es heute im
bundestag und damit beginnt die
nachrichten vom soll bericht ja denn die
abgeordneten haben schärfere regeln
beschlossen
damit gelten für händler und hersteller
künftig neue meldepflichten außerdem
werden bei bestimmten schusswaffen die
magazin größen begrenzt wer
extremistische oder
verfassungsfeindliche überzeugungen hat
soll keine waffe mehr besitzen dürfen
deshalb müssen sich die ausstellenden
behörden künftig beim verfassungsschutz
über die antragsteller informieren die
österreichische fpö hat ihren ex
vorsitzenden strache ausgeschlossen
der 50 jährige soll in mehrere skandale
verwickelt sein und musste im mai von
allen ämtern zurücktreten unter anderem
als vizekanzler
viele parteifreunde geben ihm die
mitschuld an den jüngsten
wahlniederlagen strache wurde vor allem
das sogenannte ibiza video zum
verhängnis die heimlichen aufnahmen
lassen ihn empfänglich für korruption
erscheinen
nun plant er offenbar ein comeback mit
einer neuen partei in algerien hat der
umstrittene ex regierungschef die wohnen
die präsidentenwahl gewonnen
laut wahlbehörde erreichte er schon im
ersten wahlgang 58 prozent der stimmen
das ergebnis löste neue massenproteste
aus zehntausende forderten eine
grundlegende reform des politischen
systems
unter ihrem druck war im april der
langjährige staatschef gute flickr
zurückgetreten
die bohnen gehörte wie alle kandidaten
zum alten führungszirkel der
bundesgerichtshof hat betreibern
bestimmter kindergärten den rücken
gestärkt in gebäuden in denen nicht nur
wohnungen sondern auch büros und leben
zulässig sind dürfen auch kinder
einrichtungen betrieben werden
im konkreten fall ein eltern kind
zentrum die darüber wohnenden eigentümer
müssen den kinderlärm ertragen
dieser sei per gesetz gegenüber anderen
geräuschquellen privilegiert so die
richter eine schwere gasexplosion hat
den ort blankenburg im harz erschüttert
dabei kam in einem mehrfamilienhaus ein
bewohner ums leben mindestens 15
menschen wurden verletzt
in der wohnung des toten fand die
polizei mehrere gasflaschen wozu sie
dienten ist noch unklar der heizt wird
der plattenbau mit fernwärme er wird
wahrscheinlich wochenlang unbewohnbar
sein
bundeskanzlerin merkel warb heute um
verständnis dafür dass polen als
einziges eu mitgliedsland die neuen
europäischen klimaschutzziele nicht
unterschrieben hat und tatsächlich sind
die polen auch nicht die ersten die auf
einen sonderweg pochen
man erinnere sich an die brücken die
jahrzehntelang ein finanz rabatt
bekommen solange es dabei um ökonomische
interessen geht ist das für die
staatengemeinschaft verkraftbar
schwieriger wird es wenn es um
europäische grundwerte geht etwa um
rechtsstaats prinzipien gegen polens
umgang mit seiner justiz gab es bereits
mehrere vertragsverletzungsverfahren und
klagen beim europäischen gerichtshof
trotzdem hat die polnische regierung
jetzt ein neues gesetz zur
disziplinierung von richtern vorgelegt
natalie steger bericht sie wollen sich
nicht den mund verbieten lassen
ein protest am gericht in krakau denn
wieder gibt es einen gesetzentwurf die
nationalkonservativen pis
regierungspartei legt sich erneut mit
der justiz an
es geht um nicht weniger als um bessere
möglichkeiten richter noch mehr zu
kontrollieren
die frage ist was das ziel des entwurfes
ist außerdem selbstverständlichen
politischen ziel kritiker zum schweigen
zu bringen richtern soll kritik an
verfassungsorganen verboten werden
außerdem könnten nach dem gesetzentwurf
richter abgesetzt oder sogar entlassen
werden wenn sie kollegen vorwerfen von
der regierung abhängig zu sein
einige richter fühlen irgendwelche
zweifel an dem von uns durchgeführten
reformen
sie versuchen die veränderungen in frage
zu stellen
es geht der polnischen regierung
offenbar darum ihren umbau der justiz
unumkehrbar zu machen
polenz richter werden vom sogenannten
landes justizrat ernannt der ist
mittlerweile faktisch im kies hat
genauso wie eine neu geschaffene
disziplinarkammer für richter und
staatsanwälte
der einfluss der politik auf die justiz
ist groß und soll ausgebaut werden
nicht nur die einzelnen gremien die für
die richter ernennung und für die
rechtsprechung zuständig sind an der
obersten stelle sondern also bis runter
zum zum richter am amtsgericht sozusagen
kann man dann kontrollieren ist der
loyal gegenüber der regierung fällt der
urteile die uns nicht gefallen
verfahren gegen richter laufen bereits
wie gegen pawel julius zwischen der
richter aus holstein wurde suspendiert
er hatte sich erlaubt die unabhängigkeit
eines richters anzuzweifeln
der vom landes justizrat ernannt worden
war sein fall sorgte für empörung und
proteste ich appelliere an die richter
lasst euch nicht einschüchtern lassen
auch das oberste gericht polens setzt
sich gegen die justiz politik der
regierung zur wehr
nun also die retourkutsche der
gesetzentwurf für strafen für richter es
ist eine weitere eskalationsstufe im
streit von regierung und justiz in polen
zu den schattenseiten der
digitalisierung gehört ja die teils
geradezu absurde verzerrung öffentlicher
meinungsbilder durch die erregung
maschinerien die social media bietet wer
am lautesten schreit kann sich grösster
aufmerksamkeit sicher sein
das ist allerdings kein neues phänomen
und damit kann eine gesellschaft klar
kommen schlimmer ist das gift das
täglich durch hass hetze drohungen und
verleumdungen im netz verbreitet wird
und das längst auch in der analogen welt
wirkung zeigt die bundesjustizministerin
will plattformen wie facebook oder
twitter künftig mit hohen bußgeldern
dazu zwingen straftaten wie zum beispiel
morddrohungen oder volksverhetzung von
sich aus zu melden
christiane hübscher und berkenthin
berichten anke domscheit-berg glaubt
nicht mehr entfernen es im netz die
bundestagsabgeordnete bringt brutale
beleidigungen die sie online immer
wieder erfährt längst nicht mehr zur
anzeige denn das helfe rein gar nichts
der seit drei jahren ist ein fall
anhängig da auch nicht vor gericht
gelandet ist wo mir jemand schrieb ich
soll von einwanderern tod geschickt
werden und das finde ich heißt nicht
lustig und ich finde diese person sollte
dafür auch verfolgt werden das findet
nicht statt hass und hetze im netz über
jahre nicht gelöscht wie auch im fall
des kasseler regierungspräsidenten
walter lübke
erst der mord an ihm hat in der politik
was bewegt wir haben uns daran gemacht
dass in zukunft netzwerkbetreiber nicht
nur löschen und sperren rechtswidrige
inhalte sondern dass es in zukunft auch
eine meldepflicht gibt an eine zentrale
stelle des bundeskriminalamtes
lamprechts gesetzentwurf sieht vor
sozialer netzwerke sollen künftig
strafbare inhalte mit der ip-adresse
direkt an das bka melden
das übergibt im zweifel an den
staatsanwalt bis zu 50 millionen euro
bußgeld drohen den netzwerken wenn sie
ihrer meldepflicht nicht nachkommen wir
fragen sie alle an nur facebook reagiert
heute schriftlich eine solche
meldepflicht wirft eine reihe von
rechtlichen praktischen und
gesellschaftlichen fragen auf wir werden
den gesetzentwurf prüfen
dieses gesetz was da jetzt kommen soll
ist nur ein punkt jetzt ist immer noch
die frage offen was machen wir mit dem
beleidigungs delikten weil man könnte
sagen die sind so klein aber sie werden
ja tausendfach zehntausendfach
systematisch eingesetzt um menschen
tatsächlich unter druck zu setzen und
einzuschüchtern
hier soll der straftatbestand verschärft
werden wer andere öffentlich im netz
beleidigt muss künftig mit zwei jahren
freiheitsstrafe rechnen
statt bisher einem
doch melden müssen die netzwerkbetreiber
einfache beleidigungen auch weiterhin
nicht der betroffene soll nur darüber
informiert werden dass er strafanzeige
erstatten könnte das reicht nicht
kritisieren beratungsstellen gegen hass
im netz
das problem bei beleidigung bedrohung
verleumdung ist das wenn sie dagegen
vorgehen wollen als betroffener dann
sagt ihnen staatsanwalt und eine
staatsanwältin meistens auch das ist
nicht von öffentlichem interesse und da
hätten wir uns gewünscht dass zumindest
bei den schwerwiegenden beleidigungen
die hohe reichweite haben das darin
staatsanwalt also dass das da eine
gesetzänderung gesagt das ist
öffentliches interesses müssen wir
verfolgen dazu das alte problem
gerichten und staatsanwaltschaften fehlt
es an personal
zumindest für das bka soll es jetzt 300
neue stellen geben euch jetzt nochmal
kaiser mit dem blick auf die wirtschaft
ja er übermorgen sollten in den usa neue
strafzölle inkrafttreten auf chinesische
waren im wert von 160 milliarden dollar
nun kommt diese neue eskalation im
handelsstreit doch nicht beide seiten
haben sich auf einen teil abkommen
geeinigt wie sieht dieser sogenannte
phase 1 die laus valerie haller in
frankfurt und wie reagiert die
finanzwelt darauf die finanzwelt
reagiert mit großer erleichterung der
handelsstreit er belastet ja schon die
weltkonjunktur
der deal ist noch nicht in trockenen
tüchern zwar haben beide länder die
einigung bestätigt aber unterschrieben
ist sie noch nicht
das wäre ja auch nicht das erste mal
dass beide ein teilabkommen ankündigen
dass da nicht zustande kommt fast
zeitgleich bestätigen china und die usa
die einigung die nächste runde strafzoll
ist erstmal vom tisch vor allem aber
eine weitere eskalation des streits
washington will vorerst keine neuen
zölle erheben und einen kleinen teil der
bestehenden reduzieren
china im gegenzug verpflichtet sich
künftig mehr amerikanische produkte zu
kaufen und akzeptiert strengere auflagen
bei produkt piraterie und technologie
klau ein großer teil der amerikanischen
strafzöllen bleibt bestehen als hebel
wie es aus washington heißt für die
weiteren gespräche beide seiten haben im
übrigen eine art rückversicherung
vereinbart sollten china oder die usa
ihre zusagen nicht einhalten können die
altencelle unmittelbar wieder in
auftreten die börse reagierte zunächst
euphorisch als die einigung bestätigt
wurde ging es ordentlich rauf dann aber
kamen erste zweifel hoch verständlich
nach dem auf und ab der vergangenen 17
monate glauben viele dass der
handelsstreit so schnell nicht beigelegt
ist trump jedenfalls muss die einigung
sehr gelegen kommen ausgerechnet heute
an dem tag als in washington dass im
pitch mend verfahren noch einmal fahrt
aufgenommen hat danke an die börse
valerie kommt jürgen klopp als trainer
zurück nach deutschland solche
spekulationen dürften nun erstmal
verstummen denn der 52 jährige hat
seinen vertrag beim fc liverpool
vorzeitig verlängert bis 2024
mit ihm hat liverpool die champions
league gewonnen und hat gute chancen auf
den englischen meistertitel bei der
bundesliga mussten heute abend zwei
vereine aus dem mittelfeld antreten
hoffenheim hatte augsburg zu gast gerade
ist die partie zu ende gegangen mit
einer 2 4 niederlage für hoffenheim
in neuseeland haben rettungskräfte sechs
weitere leichen schon der vulkaninsel
wake island geborgen und dabei ihr
eigenes leben aufs spiel gesetzt
nach zwei opfern wird dort noch gesucht
in einer nahegelegenen küstenstadt
trafen sich angehörige um gemeinsam zu
trauern und abschied zu nehmen
bei dem vulkanausbruch am montag waren
insgesamt 16 menschen ums leben gekommen
mehrere verletzte schweben noch in
lebensgefahr
es gibt wieder ein neues zdf
politbarometer und das präsentiert ihn
jetzt matthias fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
die spd hat sich zeit gelassen viel zeit
sechs monate und 23 regionalkonferenzen
lang hat sie nach einer neuen
doppelspitze gefahndet jetzt sind die
überraschungssieger der
mitgliederbefragung als parteichefs
gekürt saskia esken und norbert walter
borjans das motto des parteitags am
letzten wochenende in die neue zeit und
dahin soll das neue spitzenduo die spd
jetzt führen werden die beiden erfolg
haben ja meinen 23 prozent eine große
mehrheit aber 62 prozent glaubt dass
nicht die skepsis ist selbst bei spd
anhängern groß 37 prozent der befragten
trauen den vorsitzenden zu
die partei zum erfolg zu führen 42
bezweifeln das vom prinzip der schwarzen
null der vermeidung weiterer
öffentlicher schulden will die spd
abweichen um staatliche investitionen
möglich zu machen
diese idee kommt gut an drei viertel der
befragten sind dafür dass der staat mehr
investitionen tätigt auch wenn dafür
zusätzliche neue schulden gemacht werden
müssen
nur 22 prozent sind dagegen eine solche
abkehr von der schwarzen null finden die
anhänger aller parteien gut selbst die
von cdu csu und fdp
die spd will aber noch mehr einen
höheren mindestlohn etwa oder eine
vermögenssteuer der linkskurs der partei
wird von den befragten eher kritisch
gesehen
41 prozent meinen einen linkskurs wird
der spd nutzen 48 prozent aber finden
die orientierung nach links werde ihr
schaden
auch die spd anhänger sind gespalten 46
prozent glauben dass der linkskurs der
partei eher schaden wird erwartungen an
parteitage sind groß
ein signal der geschlossenheit eine
aufbruchstimmung soll von ihnen ausgehen
die auch die wähler mobilisiert das ist
offenbar nicht gelungen
grüne cdu fdp und spd mit kaum
veränderten werten nach ihren
parteitagen
wenn am nächsten sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre käme die cdu unverändert auf 27
prozent die spd verharrt mit 13 prozent
im tief ebenfalls unverändert die afg
mit 14
die fdp käme auf 8 plus 1 die linke auf
9 minus 1 die grünen erreichten
unverändert 23 prozent
schwarz-grün bliebe das einzig mögliche
zweierbündnis für grün rot rot würde es
nicht reichen
es ist viel spekuliert worden über ein
mögliches kroko aus doch die mehrheit
der befragten glaubt nicht dass es dazu
kommt 69 prozent denken die koalition
wird halten dass es zum bruch kommt
glauben nur 25 prozent
sollte die spd doch aus der groko
aussteigen plädieren 58 prozent der
befragten für neuwahlen
auch in unserer liste der wichtigsten
politiker gibt es wenig veränderungen
auf der skala von +5 bis -5 bleibt
annegret kramp karrenbauer schlusslicht
minus 0,5 platz neun für horst seehofer
0,0 leicht verbessert davor christian
lindner 0,2 auf platz 7 friedrich merz
0,3 rang sechs für jens spahn 0,4 leicht
verbessert auf dem fünften platz markus
söder 0,5 heiko maas 0,6 etwas
verbessert auf dem dritten platz olaf
scholz 0,6 mit leichten verlusten
rahn 2 held robert habeck 1,0 etwas
schlechter weiter an der spitze angela
merkel 1,3 leicht verbessert
ein blick nach großbritannien die
konservativen tories von premier bis
sonntag haben bei der wahl gestern die
absolute mehrheit geholt für johnson
dürfte es jetzt deutlich leichter sein
seine praxis pläne auch durchzusetzen
und am 31
januar 2020 die eu zu verlassen wenn
großbritannien aus der eu austritt
finden dass nur neun prozent der
befragten gut 24 prozent wäre es egal
eine deutliche mehrheit aber 65 prozent
fände ist schlecht
das jahr neigt sich dem ende zu
zeit bilanz zu ziehen und nach vorne zu
blicken
2009 10 war für drei viertel aller
befragten ein gutes jahr für 22 ein
schlechtes für das neue jahr gibt es
hohe erwartungen 30 prozent glauben 2020
wird noch besser
63 prozent rechnen damit dass sich für
sie nichts ändert nur sechs prozent
fürchten eine verschlechterung
eine große mehrheit der deutschen glaubt
also dass 2020 genauso gut oder sogar
besser wird wir optimisten
das war unser berichte über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
und auf heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards finden sie unter
politbarometer punkt zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann am
16 januar nach dem wetter geht's hier
weiter mit dem jahresrückblick der
heute-show ihnen noch einen entspannten
abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
sturmtief heißt heiko und das stürmt
schon in der nacht heran über den
ärmelkanal und frankreich und überquert
morgen auch deutschland deswegen regen
und schnee mit und vor allen dingen
sturm das mit dem wind geht schon heute
nacht los um mitternacht über frankreich
und morgen zieht dann das sturmfeld über
die eifel und den schwarzwald weiter
richtung thüringer wald und erzgebirge
und auch am dritten advent also am
sonntag bleibt es bei uns stürmisch an
den küsten da sind durchaus noch
windböen bis 90 kilometer pro stunde
möglich
heute nacht wird erst mal glatt
besonders in den mittelgebirgen die
schneefallgrenze liegt etwa bei 600
meter aber auch im nordosten kann es
glatt sein denn dort fällt der regen zum
teil auf gefrorenen boden sonst wird die
nacht etwas milder temperaturen von fünf
grad zum beispiel am oberrhein morgen
liegen dann die höchsttemperaturen bei
vier grad auf rügen und bis zu 11 grad
am oberrhein
und das wird ein sehr stürmischer und
sehr regnerischer samstag hin und wieder
ist noch schnee dabei in den
mittelgebirgen am sonntag ändert sich
das wetter an den alpen zeigt sich die
sonne und am nachmittag reißen die
wolken hier in norddeutschland mehr und
mehr auf bei temperaturen zwischen sechs
und 14 grad kann von schnee dann keine
rede mehr sein
und auch die neue woche startet doch
deutlich milder als zuletzt am dienstag
können die temperaturen bis 15 grad
steigen das was wir heute ihnen einen
schönen abend und ein schönes wochenende